[Music]
it and it chapter two are among the most
successful horror movies of the past
decade more than two years have passed
since chapter two so it came as
something of a surprise when jeff snyder
announced via the angler that an it
series was in the works the series is to
be titled welcome to dairy and will
function as a prequel to the two movies
the time period is set between the 1960s
and 1980s and will smoothly transition
into the two movies at the end of the
series there's not much information
about the series and is not known in
which form we will see it in the movies
we already see him in other forms as
pennywise and in the books there are
considerably more ghoulish characters
that it could take on behind the scenes
and the ad babara muscati serve as
producers the former having already
directed both movies also screenwriter
jason fox is no stranger because he
already participated in it chapter 2 in
the role of richie's manager by the way
andy muschietti will once again take a
seat in the director's chair for the
pilot episode it is still a nun who is
scheduled to take over after that it is
also unclear when the series will be
released we are still waiting for an
official confirmation from wander bros
this year we can look forward to house
of the dragon the latest and overall
second game of thrones series after a
good three years since the end of the
last popular eighth season of the main
series it's soon time to dive into the
past as we've known for some time the 10
episode series takes place a good 200
years before the original the focus is
on the rise and fall of the house of
targaryen and the battle for supremacy
in westeros as can be seen from the
official synopsis namely the succession
to the throne is unclear and coveted by
both king visery's son and his daughter
all the confusion eventually triggers a
civil war also known as the dance of the
dragons in the game of thrones universe
joining the cast are patty considine as
king viserys the first emma darcy has
his firstborn daughter rhaenyra
targaryen and met smith as daemon
targaryen we also see olivia cook as
renra's stepmother alice and hightower
andre's elephants as otto hightower
allison's father and the king's right
hand man we also get a fresh look from
new images that show a hatching dragon
egg as well as various characters the
script is written by hercules author
ryan connell and none other than george
r.r martin who of course also wrote the
book by the way there were first hints
about this star date recently on the
website of actress emma darcy's agency
where there was talk of august 2022
before the info was quickly deleted
again shortly thereafter the series
launch was also officially announced by
hbo accordingly house of the dragon will
be released on august 21st 2022
hasbro's ignite event titled innovation
showcase 2022 recently took place there
the toy manufacturer mainly presented
new projects for investors and
shareholders including news about the
transformers franchise hasbro released a
new poster at the center of which
incidentally strongly resembles the
matrix of leadership in addition vice
president jenny whitlock gave a brief
update on the movie according to her the
movie will be sent after the events of
bumblebee and will tell the story of
optimus prime bumblebee and a group of
human allies they all have to stand up
to the beasts making a dream of
transformers followers finally come true
fans of the 90 series beast wars in
particular are likely to look forward to
the return of optimus primal eraser and
co in any case we are also looking
forward to the new transformers rise of
the beasts the movie is scheduled for
release on june 9th 2023
last sunday the annual academy awards
took place for the 94th time in los
angeles after last year's event pretty
much flopped this year the oscar
ceremony was the talk of the town the
reason will smith who slapped comedian
chris rock in the face due to a joke
against his wife but that's not what
we're here to talk about because as
every year we'll briefly introduce you
to the most important winners of the
oscars this year koda won the award for
best picture the apple tv plus movie was
sent into the race for the most
important prize relatively late but then
it did win the oscar beforehand many
experts agreed that the netflix movie
the power of the dog had the best
chances of winning the prize but we're
wrong in the end however jane champion
won the award for best director for this
movie on the actor's side will smith for
king richard and jessica chastain for
the eyes of tammy faye cleaned up the
top prize in the best lead actor
category the best supporting actors were
troy kadzur for coda and ariana the bose
for west side story other winning movies
included encounter for best animated
film drive my car for best international
film and summer of seoul for best
documentary both westside story and
belfast were nominated in total of seven
categories but could win only one each
the winner of the evening however at
least by numbers was the science fiction
hit dune which took home six oscars the
categories include best's original score
best sound and best cinematography we
are curious to see when the sequel will
also celebrate success in the main
categories at the oscars in 2024
last tuesday sad news reached the
hollywood world bruce willis ends his
acting career this was announced by the
family of the 67 year old in a short
message the reason is said to be aphasia
which is a kind of speech disorder this
decision which the family made public
shortly after willa's birthday had been
considered carefully which is why it can
be assumed that the actor has been
suffering from the disease for some time
to this day bruce willis is primarily
associated with a die hard film series
which gave him his big breakthrough in
the 1980s he is considered one for
hollywood's biggest action stars even
though his last years were marked by
many b-movies either way he will sorely
be missed as an iconic actor and we wish
him all the best
many children of the 90s should be
familiar with his spy kids franchise
because the family movie by robert
rodriguez released in 2001 has become
iconic there are already a total of four
movies and even an animated series and
as we learned this week another movie is
currently in the planning stages as
deadline reports netflix is planning a
reboot of the children's movie series
and as with every previous movie
rodriguez will once again take a seat in
the director's chair together with him
netflix thus wants to race pockets to a
contemporary level which should
certainly please many in addition the 53
year old rodriguez is still the
screenwriter and producer of the movie
at the same time he and netflix have
also already proven that they can work
well together as the 2020 children's
superhero movie we can be heroes was
also directed by him of course we
shouldn't expect a familiar cast to
return as the titular spy kids after all
some of the kids from the first part are
already over 30 and don't quite pass for
kids anymore in any case we're looking
forward to robert rodriguez new spy kids
movie a release date is unfortunately
not yet known
only recently the news went through the
world that amazon has bought mgm it
looks like the first series project for
the comedy james bond series which now
also belongs to amazon is already
planned however double 07's row 2
million is not a story series about the
movies but a kind of reality tv in which
various candidates have the opportunity
to win a million pounds they have to
duel each other both physically and
mentally at well-known locations from
the franchise the selection process is
still underway so a start date is not
yet known the anticipation among fans
doesn't seem to be all that great
considering the reactions to the
announcement apart from filming
locations double07s wrote to a million
doesn't seem to have much to do with the
movie series
we hope you enjoyed our news again this
time we also have some other exciting
videos for you on our channel this week
be sure to check out the second trailer
from minions 2 or the latest preview for
a possible moana 2 movie if you haven't
watched it already
[Music]
foreign
[Music]